[Applause]
now we all know you by the way i've been
practicing i did not want to
screw up your name and i think i just
did because that's so lightweight
you didn't you got it you got it great
it was milo
oh god see it's happening by the way
it's the mouth
so we all know you i know you as jack
pearson but
we wanted to get to know you a little
better are you game for a rapid-fire
question okay great yeah all right let's
do it all right now
i'm a long-winded person i i struggle to
be like
you know i'm fast like in wit but
slow i give all these words and analogy
so this is probably going to be a bigger
challenge for me than it is for you um
are you long-winded too uh i'm i think
i'm in the middle
sometimes it takes me a while to tell a
story like but then i got a little voice
in the back of my
my head that says just land the plane
man right wrap it up edit
um well okay so we're gonna try to do
this in
one minute it's milo in a minute
okay are you an open book person or are
you a keep it close to the
chest uh close to the chest oh well
let's go then
okay first person you call when you get
good news
uh russ my producing partner or my mom
the last time you cried
uh probably a couple days ago so close
to the chest but a softy okay
first celebrity crush i think i think it
might have been
alyssa milano or somebody from like oh
my god
i used to go around with her and yeah we
i i had a crush on her
um okay one skill set you wish you could
have
um am i wishing to play the piano what
was the last text you sent
it was to my publishers gina gina i
think i messed up on the username and
sign in wait i figured it
out the last movie you watched
lethal weapon two oh good one what makes
you nervous
not a whole lot brave the last mistake
you made
um that same text i was trying to send
to my publicist gina
i accidentally sent it to somebody else
whose name first name starts with the g
and i hadn't returned a message to that
person in a year
it's been so fun and i love questions
like that because you know i mean we go
on
you know a test circuit and you get
asked those same questions over and over
and i would like kill just to get a
fresh question
yeah totally totally i agree i feel like
i could tell more about
myself by my favorite crayon in the
crayola box
than the what was your motivation for
this character which just sounds
very what is what is your favorite
crayon in the crayola box
periwinkle periwinkle it's a really nice
blue
it is like a purple blue yes it's the
best color
really subtle yeah it's beautiful cutest
name because it has
wink in it i always liked forest
forest it was like a strong green but it
wasn't too bright
and it just reminded me of being outside
yeah
i i will not look at forest the same way
i mean it's really simple it's not quite
as as cool as periwinkle but
forest i don't know it reminds you of
being outside
that's i'm gonna have to draw all over
my manhattan apartment with it
[Applause]
perfect thank you milo so
much for coming here today visiting
hanging out trying to do something
different and i think
hopefully our conversation was exactly
that thank you
absolutely anytime drew lovely to see
you lovely to see you too
this is us airs tuesday on 9 8
central on nbc